♪ Now missing me ♪
- Alcool, absence de
distanciation, de port
du masque, jusqu'à l'usage
de vapoteuse en plein vol,
la fête du vol nolisé de Sunwing
du 30 décembre dernier est
désormais sous enquête par
le gouvernement fédéral.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Je peux vous assurer que
Transports Canada prend très
au sérieux la situation avec
ce vol nolisé.
- Du New York Post aux
États-Unis au Daily Mail
en Angleterre, les gestes et
comportements du groupe de
150 influenceurs ont fait
le tour du monde au cours
des derniers jours.
HARARI HASSIN, expert aviation
- Un avion avec plus d'une
centaine de passagers à
30 000 pieds, ce n'est pas
un chalet dans la forêt dans
lequel on peut tout faire.
- Bien au chaud sur les plages
du Mexiques, plusieurs fêtards
ont produit des vidéos pour
narguer ceux qui désapprouvaient
leurs gestes et comportements.
- En plus, quand les gens
sont en train de faire
des sacrifices. Les gens ont
réduit leurs contacts pendant
le temps des Fêtes, ont pas
vu des êtres chers. Et quand
une gang de sans-desseins
qui décide de partir comme
des Ostrogoths en vacances.
C'est extrêmement frustrant.
- De plus, certains membres du
groupe de fêtards, qui cherchent
maintenant à rentrer au Canada,
se sont partagés des conseils
pour éviter l'isolement
obligatoire en cas de tests
positifs à la COVID.
C'est peut-être finalement
la justice qui va ramener
ces influenceurs sur terre.
Pour un non-respect de
la réglementation aérienne,
la loi prévoit des amendes
jusqu'à 5000 $ par infraction.
Pour une fausse déclaration
lors de son entrée au Canada,
il est prévu des amendes
jusqu'à 750 000 $, ou encore
6 mois d'emprisonnement.
Finalement, pour mettre en
danger la vie d'autrui lors
d'un vol, il est prévu des
amendes jusqu'à 1 million de
dollars, ou encore, trois ans
d'emprisonnement.
PATRICE LAVOIE, vice-président,
Qc, H+K Stratégies Canada
- Je ne vois pas une marque
ou une entreprise qui voudrait
s'associer à nouveau pour
une collaboration ou pour
la promotion d'un produit avec
ces gens-là. Cette situation-là
a eu un impact, je dirais,
négatif sur la fonction
marketing d'influence.
- Pour l'heure, c'est plutôt de
trouver le moyen de rentrer au
pays qui préoccupe les membres
du groupe d'influenceurs, car
plusieurs transporteurs aériens
refusent maintenant de
les prendre à bord
de leurs appareils.
Ici Pascal Robidas,
Radio-Canada, Montréal